tonight will be ross stripling making
his 18th start he's also had a game
pitched out of the bullpen for the blue
jays he won his last start his fourth
game of the season that was against
kansas city last time
bradley zimmer swings at the first pitch
it eats up guerrero and it might have
got him on the bare thumb bradley
zimmer's aboard
not running
breaking ball hit on the one hop
second for one back to first no throw
runners on the corners and two out
breaking ball hit the third espanol goes
to sack and what a nice play never
hesitated at all
and tristan in his last start it was a a
barn burner so hopefully he doesn't walk
anybody make these js hit their way on
the one-two pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out that
was some really good pitching
right hey again i miss and tristan
mckenzie hot knife through butter
called strike three the fastball on the
outside corner into the line the 2-1
swing at a pop-up back of second simeon
drifting through the new turf back
pedaling now called up by grichik coming
in from right he's there and ross
stripling spins a three-up three-dim
outing in the second
here's the 2-1 offering
and it's swung on and another fly ball
to center boy he is just pounding the
blue chase with fastballs and getting
routine fly-outs as he has another one
two three inning with bradley zimmer
making the jets
choo-choo pitch hard hit to left field
that long run for gurilla is he going to
get there yes
nice running catch for ludus guriel ross
stripling has another one two three
inning go to the bottom of the third
still a scoreless game
popular elevation
two away and that'll bring up the
catcher reese maguire
as a breaking ball pop to shallow left
harold ramirez makes the catch and on
nine pitches tristan mckenzie sets him
down one two three the only base runners
we've had in the top half of the first
inning cleveland ended up stranding two
nobody has reached base since on either
side
and he came back three straight
change-ups from stripling
fastball gets him
stripping strikes out too
top of the order for the blue jays when
we come back
3-2 pitch to springer
fastball swung on and missed strike
three
vladimir guerrero jr rolls in
ground ball through the left side base
hit for vladi guerrero
that's the first base runner for the
blue jays
the shed bats the pitch by mckenzie
swing in the drive get up ball get out
of here and yeah
both the [ __ ]
with number 20
and the blue jays are on the board
i mean he locked back on that thing
recognized it let it break and then went
after that thing and hit it a mile
boy that young man can hit and he got
his former teammate in the futures game
there's the indians first hit of the
game
and owen miller delivers a one-out
single here in the fifth
that is a nasty change-up called strike
three
hedges strikes on
there's a high pop-up into the outfield
springer broke back
gretchen calls for it the right fielder
comes over to make the catch ross strip
cling five innings in the books and he
leaves with a two-nothing lead
santiago espinal jumps on that pitch and
rips it into left field big turd around
first and then get it back in quickly so
he gets his first hit of the night a two
out single this third hit for the blue
jays
and with the shift on he hit it right to
ernie clement to end the inning
called strike three as slider catches
the inside corner
and there's a fastball rifled into right
field just what you said take it the
other way he does that and now you've
got runners at the corners with one out
one and two
change up swinging a miss a big
strikeout for stripling
[Applause]
ground ball this will do it flip to
second and what an outing for ross
stripling
3-2 pitch to simian
rip to left field and fair
all the way into the corner simeon is
headed for second and he'll get there
with the double his 27th double of the
season comes with two outs here in the
sixth and here comes bovichette
officially after a mount visit with
austin hedges
breaking ball up the middle that's going
to score another run symbiote around
third and bow has driven in all three
blue jay runs another clutch hit for
boba's ship a two out rbi single
trevor richards into the game for the
blue jays
well there's a weak swing and a papa
behind first claddy is there makes the
catch
fastball on the ground simeon is right
there
nice clean inning for trevor richards
three up three down we'll go to the
bottom of the seventh
and a liner to right caught
by mercado and so that
officially makes that makes this his
longest start of the season
there you go the fastball
fourth strike out of the night for
tristan mckenzie equaling his season
high with seven innings of work
strong goes after the first pitch
espinal was in close oh what a play
santiago espinal was in close guarding
against the bun gets a little chopper
and bare handed it and threw all in one
motion to gun down the speedy straw
[Applause]
there's a slider little looper into
center springer closing quickly and
that'll end the inning
look out oh that hit him on the hand
he wears that pad for a reason and
hopefully that was the hand that got hit
but he is fine and he will take his base
here's adam simber
coming in to try to close things out
there it is that's the ball game simper
strikes out mercado
he picks up the save
stripling picks up his fifth win and the
blue jays threw a shutout for the ninth
time this season